hey what's up guys it's hans kim here
and we're doing the hanskim
podcast.com welcome to the podcast
live from sixth street uh
recorded on sixth street we got jordan
shelby in the house yes
martial arts
master you know this is real brick yeah
it's pretty cool yeah excited to be here
at
this is an old building but it's like
done up nice are we at trailer is this
trailer headquarters
seems like yeah this is one of those
places where people stand up at their
desks yeah this is a cool office
it is very cool office yeah they don't
believe in
where do you think the money came from
uh the ibel money
[Music]
yeah where do you work again
i work for a
an entertainment company oh
not as close here i'm not going to out
myself on this
yeah okay i'm about to drop away is it
because like bad words this is an
entertainment company and that's an
entertainment company and you don't want
them to see cheating on them no i'm
going to get fired soon but i don't want
to get fired sooner than i have to
yeah yeah
due diligence yeah you don't want to
act like you don't want to feel like you
deserved to be homeless and out of a job
i want to get fired on my terms yeah
yeah you want to do it for the reasons
that are egregious and not the petty
uh undisciplined shitty you know trashy
reasons to get fired yeah i want
something for my act you know how we do
everything like it might go in the act
yeah
yeah
yeah the good old act it's always
getting replenished with new life events
do you get a lot of not mine
yeah
[ __ ] start
wordplay
yeah it's a good sound my act is about
wordplay
this is mostly a dictionary reading
um
but yeah i mean i uh i
whenever something happens i feel the
pressure to make it into a joke but i'm
always yeah yeah it's something
important that you don't just let it
yeah be your life yeah
i just well i do let it be my life but
then like when i do comedy they're like
man
you live in a van why don't you joke
about that more
mm-hmm
but you know things people think you
should talk about interact yeah yeah
it's weird because like some things like
i do it and then it's just like um you
know i don't think it's funny like i
just do it for a lot a lot of my life i
don't think like
i'm sometimes sad i'm sometimes funny
but i'm not like funny all the time yeah
even though i'm a killed me neither i'm
pretty much only funny on stage i think
yeah
i don't pretty boring and personally
yeah i tried to be i go out of my way to
be boring it's a it's a useful tool is
it yeah you found it to be useful in
your life yeah so you're not in a van
anymore no i moved into a home do you
think that's bad for your brand no it's
the only homeless asian person in
america i'm using my brand to get me a
home
oh you're using your brand of living in
a van to get in a home yeah i mean why
you're so [ __ ] smart
i uh i just don't um i i'll use my
[ __ ] you know brand
to do things but i and talk to me about
your brand can't really
care about
what's the hans brand no i i guess i
could be egotistical um my brand is
probably like
um
like
stoner or like um petulant vulnerability
petroleum vulnerabilities your brand's a
very
heady brand you got in there dude thanks
yeah that's cool i like it
yeah
what's your brand
laid back
like a laid-back mustache these days but
i think i'll probably go soon
yeah
you're gonna
spike it up so it's not so laid-back you
can do a mustache i don't see a lot of
korean mustaches out there yeah i would
love to do a mustache and you love that
yeah i think it's nice it looks thick
enough from here earth to grow into one
like
yeah i've done it before
it's just really do you trim it with
those little scissors and that little
comb i have a comb and i just do the
same like
face razor just like
closely on the mustang i don't really
know i did it because i was bored during
the pandemic
the only reason i still have it is
because i don't want to deal with people
like
reacting when it's gone yeah
it's all those people that are careful
the people that love your face and will
notice when things are different why
would you want them to
people just get used to your face and
they freak out when it changes a little
bit yeah like a baby
yeah mostly babies yeah are concerned
with my face and mustache
yeah i mean i think it's fine to
do
facial hair now
i disagree
um but i don't think it's fine you do uh
jiu jitsu or
really badly
like i said i'm just doing it for
because it
and boy do i not want to talk about
doing jiu jitsu on a comedy blog yes but
yeah i do it because uh i i've always
loved martial arts and combat sports
have a little bit of a background in it
and what's your background in it i like
and i want just traditional ckd which is
yeah the most useless
martial art if not coupled with
it's like you can kick someone in the
face and do nothing else like it's it's
actually not it's not practical at all
unless you know how to do other things
well
it's practical if you are kicking
someone really hard that's true fast but
if you miss then you're getting your ass
kicked well hopefully you practice not
missing
i you know what
you're smart
i should do that well because joe rogan
just did take one dough as a base and
there are giant holes in it but i'm
nowhere near like
boxing or like wrestling yeah but
there's holes in boxing
not yet exactly but
not as many as yeah it's a good
supplement to other martial arts but
yeah yeah just like we were saying
before i just like it too uh
it's easier for me to work out if i'm
developing a skill so yeah that's um do
you often imagine yourself fighting off
enemies all the time yeah all sorts of
enemies
is there uh
that's just for me just for your own
sake just for the passion of kicking
it's just protecting yourself that's my
brand is kicking ass
and saving
i don't think anyone thinks that you
have a background in martial arts when
they see you
that's good that's why i don't want to
be talking about it on this bike on this
podcast right now so what would you
rather you want to come trying to be
doing i want to talk about why you went
two buttons undone instead of one or all
the way up today
um two i uh i was wearing a neck pillow
when i did this and i also just so you
know if you're trying to attack me i
have pepper spray so it doesn't matter
how good i am
yeah martial arts but sorry tell me i'm
gonna buy a gun i'm really excited about
it i've registered to vote
because i don't have a texas id and i
don't want to switch everything over so
i just registered to vote and apparently
you can do it with that
can't you just
get one
without anything here they don't make it
that easy
why are we here then i thought that's
one of the big benefits i know
well i've been trying to get a gun i've
been here a year i almost have it now
um
you've been trying to get a gun for a
year in texas you're doing something
wrong i know no way it's not what it's
sold is it because you were in a van and
they're like we can't give it to you
that's pretty much part of it yeah if i
had a place it would be easy to prove my
residence
but yeah just show them a pin
of your residence when you're in a van
this is where i was yeah google maps
just share my location
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
i am going to get a gun that's the
ultimate martial art for now as opposed
to brandon drone or a nuclear weapon
could you get a drone yeah civilian
drones yeah you can make a drop
tannerite or something put a little
what did you just say tannerite what is
that it's like c
i don't know exactly what it is but i
know rednecks it's like clay and then
you like paste it onto different [ __ ]
and if you shoot it it explodes
well
it's a it's just redneck c4 yeah yeah
it's like the next level of c4 oh cool
and it's cheap you can buy it
online you can get like a tub of it
ordered to your house right now
and it's just some sort of chemical
reaction when the bullet yeah was uh
something something
that was no idea but it blows up and
it's cool yeah no because how is a
bullet hitting something like if you hit
me with the bullet i wouldn't explode i
mean no but it must be like you know how
oobleck changes
form
you know what black is like if you hit
it quickly it becomes a solid it must be
yes the opposite of that i guess yeah
along the lines of
that kind of if you shot oopleck with a
gun
would it
it would shatter like a glass the bullet
brittle
right yeah the bullet would travel to
another dimension
where doctor strange is very curious
about that
do we get some new black in here
i can't believe you know what it's
called
do you remember oobleck i don't know the
brand name i don't think it's a brand i
think it's a oh like you a thing you
make for science class
i i mean what does it stand for what
what's the language
of origin
what does it stand for i wish i was
funny enough to
give you an acronym but i have no idea
it's just it's like when they you make
the volcano in science classes same
thing then you do an oobleck lesson and
then you what school did you go to
fancy private school it's a fancy la
private school i did i'm very middle
class but i'm also an only child so my i
went to uh they told you private school
every compound and chemical you're using
no they're more just like concerned with
us going to college so they could
list where we went to college
that's kind of where did you go to
school gross
um bellevue christian school
is that a private high school yeah
but a lot of our academic uh
energy was parlayed into religion so
we weren't as strict on getting good
grades that sounds useless
exactly
i feel like we both carry a little bit
of private school energy with us
actually yeah yeah i don't think that's
good but i think yeah i think we do it
well i mean hopefully ideally in the
future everyone would go to private
school and like
you wouldn't have to you know the only
reason why it's [ __ ] up is because
we're living with a bunch of savages who
tore each other apart during lunch they
had two lunches like animals wait what
did i do i missed this transition were
you talking about your school right
there no the public schools oh right
yeah gross
yeah i i mean i don't know i don't think
it's good to spank your children or have
school you don't think spanking's good
open
i mean
it not if it's like a structured thing
like tonight you're going to get spanked
child i don't think that's how people
will do it
i don't think there's like a calendar
well it seems like 13 days we're going
to spank your ass that's what it feels
like when some people talk about it
they're like i'm gonna i love spanking
kids it's gonna happen for everyone says
that i love spanking kids yeah thank you
that's like an important part of their
identity like they're like people that
hit children i think a little bit of
public school
and a little bit of spanking your kids
is good i think there's a limit
but yeah
you can either spank them like five
times or you could hit them once
whatever
yeah
i mean i think that there is entirely
too much
public school energy in our pop culture
with like uh
cardi b
cardi b you think cardi b's public
school and yeah
ged energy
yeah
we can't do what she does
no
[Music]
i can't no i don't i mean if i could i'd
be a completely different person
that's true
have you tried twerking before
yeah
you can do a joke at a party i don't
know probably not really hard yeah i
mean you got to articulate your hips
you do you need good hip flexibility
yeah you got to think of it like a joint
like a ball and socket just gotta is
that tell me more about how you have to
think about it
this sounds painful i feel like i'm
gonna break my back if i do it
yeah i don't know i know i've tried
before i look ridiculous well yeah i
don't know you seem pretty skinny and
tall and lanky so but that's not good
twerking dimensions yeah you got a short
bounce
short and the jiggle yeah
yeah you gotta the bounce and the jiggle
yeah so you should call this podcast
who is are you the bouncer the jiggle
i am the bounce
final answer because you're what is the
difference between a bounce and a jiggle
let's really get into the bounce
relationship i feel like a jiggle is a
higher frequency bounce
so it's just bouncing that happens
i feel like a jiggle is left to right
but it bounces up up and down yeah like
a ball
right you're not j exactly you're not
you're like
jiggle happens within the confines of
the object and a balance happens in the
environment
this is private school right here
and that's why jesus is lord yeah
oh so so the pride yeah you're saying
the private element is mainly was mainly
religion
yeah i mean if you're an idiot you could
just be like well at least i love jesus
a lot yeah it really made you know
a good christian man didn't it
at what age were you like no to this
like
freshman year of high school
early yeah
was there a coalition of people who
agreed that it was all [ __ ] that you
were doing or was it just you quietly in
your head i mean like i don't believe
this at all i don't think it was said
out loud i think i don't even know if i
was fully like this isn't real but i
felt like i felt that way
but uh yeah i mean i don't i don't think
that's true i think it's
um pretty obvious is made up
did you
did they teach evolution in addition to
not really
i mean they taught it they were like
yeah it exists and they weren't like
they just like glossier
yeah that chapter
get through this one
yeah it
evolved past the pages real quick
um
that was very smooth evolve and revolve
um
but yeah i mean it was pretty
progressive christian school for
christian schools
they're like yeah like sort of the vibe
was like this might not be true but
we're just going to teach it anyways
right did you uh did you have to go to
do they have a church service yeah every
thursday
thursday it was a chapel
nice
has there been any controversy since you
left about i have died the usual
christian controversies
places like that i wonder if they have a
trans person there
i wonder it has to be
i mean
i
does there have to be yeah how big was
the school
like 400 kids
in the whole and there's how many trans
people per
400
i would say three
especially now like especially nowadays
i don't think you could
[Laughter]
especially now
yeah
well back in my day wasn't a thing as
much yeah but i think the the
what you would say is there were always
trans people but just now that i guess
they real they know they're more
actualized in their
identity
three to every 400 sounds good slightly
under 100 but yeah i have no idea
yeah it's hard to say do you think jesus
was a trans person
um sure
he trained what isn't there transcendent
he trans he transitioned from uh mortal
to a deity or i guess he was always a
deity
and he transitioned from an earthly form
into a
corporeal form
yeah but um the eucharist you uh you
love the trans are you a supporter
no you asked me a hard question
i am a supporter of the trans i support
the trans yeah i think that means
there's like the real like ones that are
like serious and then there's like ones
that are just like on board
um
well i don't know i'm not gonna i don't
i'm not connect like deeply i took a
couple classes in college where i
learned about
you know gender identity and stuff and
it made sense to me and then beyond that
i'm like [ __ ]
i'll take your word for it i think like
even if you are like i'm bored i want to
change my gender you should be able to
like it who gives a [ __ ] like you should
be able to do that
i don't think yeah sure i think like the
conservative like um
hatred of the trans is way more
egregious than
the choices that some people make
about their gender
um right and they think that yeah that
makes sense yeah the hatred is is is a
bigger issue than the going too far and
allowing people to yeah express
themselves yeah i mean there's always
going to be weirdos
yeah i think they're probably some
weirdos in there these days that
shove their way into that community
this stuff about like i get the pronouns
and stuff like that but when it's like
the color of my bracelet is what you
have to call me today it's a little bit
simon says it's kind of weird yeah yeah
um yeah i mean i haven't really but i do
support i only hear about everyone well
i never have actually
like you know
they're just like a [ __ ] you know
it's like you're crazy i never hear of
what i never talk to i never like
i don't have a best it's not a lot no
there aren't a lot of community
i feel like they're more in the comedy
community than yeah right yeah it's a
very more progressive and
yeah artistic they have a lot more
accepting of
fringe
people since forever and um
that what is valued in the comedy
community is not your identity did you
just crack your job yeah what the hell
was that
i have i have a jaw thing
you have a jaw thing is it because of
your underbite yeah i mean
that is my jaw thing and it makes you
crack your jaw like that yeah is that
from all the smooching you've been doing
you have to crack your jaw
is it like really weird like you can't
do that
crack my jaw like that no i can't just
like
move my face and have it make a noise
yeah it's probably not good
it probably is like a lot of stress and
tension it's kind of intimidating like
if we were about to fight and you did
that i'd be like maybe not
yeah maybe i have like a piston you know
like my body it's like those lobsters
that can boil water because of how fast
they can shoot a spike
like use their claw or like yeah it's
like the clock closes no idea what
you're talking about right now a piston
that can boil water lobster cloth
these
lobsters
have like little gears they look like
little gears if you zoom in and then
they can we're talking about real
lobsters right yeah
lobsters have gears yes
like microscopic gears and they can
ratchet their [ __ ] uh claw and then
when a fish comes by they like it let's
go or whatever and it like snaps shut
that's like the internal anatomy for how
it is for how it closes yeah and that
relates to my jaw because right because
that's why you're afraid of me it's
because because your jaw is like a
lobster that kind of flows dangerously i
get it yeah yeah and that's exactly what
i meant by that yeah
i went through a lot of orthodontistry
as a child
and i think that was a kind of a quack
sign your teeth are still like that
yeah my jaw is all [ __ ] up
but uh you got a nice man i got a
charming smile thanks yeah it's good
it's just like yeah i mean
what did they do that's a very private
school thing
yeah expenses
[ __ ] with your mouth for no reason
did it help
i mean i don't think so
yeah i mean you still your jaws still
like that did was it for the underbite
they tried to fix that yeah
did you
braces retain her what they did yeah
they did
just in your mouth
they didn't
molest me
they didn't moles that's good that's a
good orthodontist
yeah that's part of the social us or the
mental aspect of fixing your underbite
is don't get molested
if you get molested it sets back your
recovery that's true that's what they
say when they put
my braces on they're like make sure it's
only stuff you want in there or else
it'll [ __ ] things up yeah yeah they gave
you little weapons in your mouth in case
someone molested you
that is true like grind it down but your
teeth are pretty good
you don't need more weaponry in there
yeah
i kept don't know what we're talking
about right now but i did have braces
for i did have braces for a while and it
was stupid
yeah my parents regret it they're like
why
did we do that do they still do braces
is it like the opposite or is it all
invisible now yeah
uh yeah the braces to transgender curve
like as braces have gone down transient
um probably
with my braces it was so they
they were like your
teeth are [ __ ] up which they weren't
um but then they're like we have to
spread them all out and then bring them
all together which when um there i'm
like okay i guess that makes sense but
then in retrospect they're like they're
just [ __ ] with me like yep bring them
all apart like bring them back together
yeah it's like a
contractor that you don't really trust
they're like yeah we're gonna have to
tear this whole thing down we're to put
it up again
just like i wasn't even talking about
this part of the house
it's over here
oh yeah that too yeah to build your
kitchen we have to destroy your toilet
and then rebuild it you know what
yeah but i mean
um you know maybe after the vietnam war
we were like who are we as a generation
we have nowhere else left to conquer
let's just start
[ __ ] with middle class people
create an industry
or maybe they were like yeah like they
trusted the technology of their time and
they were like we can do anything with
this i'm tired of my kid looking ugly
right we're gonna fix this once and for
all
and in terms of the vietnam war what
side were you on
this is second nation the vietnamese
side which is good because they were on
both sides of that thing
they were it was a terrible period in
our nation's history all around
not as bad as their nation's history
yeah i would say so
because it happened over there yeah for
us it was like a bad dream it's like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
did you watch the ken burns vietnam yeah
i loved it it's amazing yeah amazing
runs all together for me with the
vietnam and the
civil war and everything he did
oh all these documentaries you mean
there it's just all it's all the same
thing it's like this is amazing but it's
all
yeah 20 hours of the same day yeah they
were using muskets in the beginning and
then they started
yeah i heard they used muskets in the
vietnam war that's why it took so long
yeah then they made the george
washington bridge or
the brooklyn bridge
um but yeah the vietnam like the
tet offensive mm-hmm i remember that
word yeah
they started out early
then they did the protests and yeah i
think i remember it
and this is not an asian thing which
side would you have rather been on
the communist side it would have been
cooler huh yeah like
doing the bamboo spike pits and stuff
like that taking americans guns buddy
yeah although i would have liked to do
this thing as you cross the river that
seems cool
really yeah holding a gun above your
head
the water's coming up from the river
yeah um yeah that's cool yeah it seems
like it does seem like it would have
been more fun to be on helicopter you
couldn't have been riding helicopters if
you're a nva
yeah in fact that would have been
probably the worst part
is the error superiority that
superiority that the americans had yeah
and the technological superiority and
how they would like light you on fire
whenever they were but besides that cool
to be on
orange that your kids now have to yeah
like have a deformed head
um but yeah i mean if you could survive
it
you were just in your pajamas you were
sleeping with your buddies yeah i think
they were in their pajamas and you were
like in the dark with the one of those
one of those things that seems fun to
use one of those yeah darting americans
yeah that's what i would have done i
would have been you know how they were
like infamous
uh soldiers
i would have been the guy like this the
whatever the shadow of vietnam will dart
you in the neck
and they'd be talking about me
yeah
did they use darts in vietnam i don't
remember that
i think they have they used them
anywhere
in the jungle book yeah
is that a scene in the jungle but i
don't know do they have a vietnam scene
in the jungle it just seems like you
don't remember that like a primitive
culture
yeah like in loincloth
yeah i don't think that our thing
actually is real it sounds like yeah i
mean it's good if you need it silently
but it's not silent because you can hear
that
you always hear the noise of the dart
firing you know yeah you have to get a
silencer for it
on your own
yeah
yeah um maybe i just fart into it
i think that's the proper technique
do you think you can get more
velocity coming out of your butt or your
mouth
um
i think you can get a more continuous
velocity coming out of your anus
more continuous see i would have said
the opposite i would have said i bet you
can get higher velocity wind coming out
of your butthole but you can control it
better coming out of your mouth you're
probably right about that yeah
yeah you are a martial artist yeah i
know all about butt control
from my days at the shaolin temple
that is a good thing to know
so do you like being on top or on bottom
i'm more of a middle you know 50 50 yeah
on your side
um did you learn this interview
technique from kill tony
okay what's up what's your sex life
just
brash and
un forgiving
no um i just like the art of jiu jitsu i
think it has a lot of parallels to life
and strategy it's like the art of war
yeah absolutely i think anything that
connects you to your body like that is
is very useful as a as a human
what about vr
i haven't i have no i've never tried it
i haven't been um
i haven't had enough money to buy one or
known someone who has one of those
things
is it like a good car sick could you run
into a cabinet or something when you
drive
um yeah it was cool it was good uh i
think vr i mean you said did you need to
connect to your body i think like isn't
that kind of the opposite of that
disconnecting from your body is good too
and sure at times definitely yeah
but
i don't know like i think it like we
were talking about earlier i think you
get you have more control of if you
control your body you control your mind
control your body sort of thing yeah
yeah um
i agree with you wholeheartedly thank
you
i appreciate it
so uh we did a show at the romo room
another room yeah the north formerly
yeah the north star whatever
what did you think about the whole
experience
oh it was good i thought the shows were
good yeah i was impressed like a ton of
ton of people there and those fun shows
that room's always a little bit it's not
like i mean comics are always like this
room isn't perfect therefore i [ __ ]
hate it but
um it's not it's not the most reliable
place to do comedy but it is it was fun
hurricanes do you think it's because
they're sitting up high and like they're
at the same level as a comedian so they
don't respect it because they're not
looking up at him
uh no i think they just don't respect me
because they see me like i don't respect
that guy but i i don't know like situ
the psychology of com psychology of
comedy rooms is
i don't really understand it sometimes i
get like low ceilings dark audience but
then there are other times just some
weird it's just the energy
of the place aroma room also their sound
is
a little bit
bad yeah
and um because they took out all this
[ __ ] because the guy that
owns it was like um taken off and he
took the spotlight he took the sound
equipment really
yeah oh yeah there was no spotlight huh
but you get the worst like the video you
get terrible tapes from there because
your eyes are just in darkness and you
look like
demon caucasian face with oh your eyes
because you a
are never under shadow yeah they're
always well lit hand face
i would never even thought about that
it's interesting i'm jealous you can't
shadow your eyes at all
yeah i mean
if i sweat it just goes right in there
that sucks your eyebrows don't do
anything yeah they're so high up too
they are kind of high there's like so
much distance are they higher up or is
it just because your eyes don't go as
hot like does it appear that way
visually um yeah that's why they're high
up is because
i have extra eyelids i have an extra
bunch of eyelids up here
but i mean you know how they're like
they're those optical illusions where
it's like is the they like have a line
going through a circle or something like
is the line straight or is it bending
yeah is that is that the same thing with
your eyebrows like are your eyebrows
higher or your eyes just
asian
i mean yeah there's a lot more eyeballs
see if you do that yeah then it's like
close completely normal yeah
i look like a white man
thank god thank god you look like an
ugly white dude yeah that's the goal
um
yeah i mean i saw like
an asian guy that looked like an ugly
white dude and i was like that guy
has the keys to our
to our race
how does an asian guy look like an ugly
white dude he was balding he had big
eyes he had like a pot belly
gross
yeah
not a very flattering description of
white people but yeah kind of accurate
this is the master race
do white people bald the earliest
of everyone i think they might maybe
i mean black people i feel like they
don't bald that much
they're their hair is different
no i don't but lebron's involved
generally thick and beautiful but yes
there is a whole thing with ron baldwin
but everyone bald at some point it's
just when yeah i have a bunch of
canadian family and they all bald
immediately so i think that brand of
white might be the quickest
yeah bald
they're just like get rid of the hair
now we're going out into the tundra
exactly you'd think they would be
hairier yeah
they should be it's like a hat
it's like you always have a hat on
um you're so [ __ ] smart
hair is like a hat
have you seen that fly of the concords
where they make a helmet out of hair too
many decks on the dance floor yeah
that's the only one uh they make a
helmet out of hair yeah they put they
got a helmet they just put hair on it so
it doesn't look like he's wearing a
helmet it just looks like his hair i
love them so much
yeah they're so innocent
yeah are they well they yeah the way
they just yeah i guess they are huh the
way they they like navigate like
the more sexual songs and stuff is very
goofy yeah yeah
really talented though
yeah
that's what we're all gonna be like
without any um guns you know just
totally like oh why'd you do that
oh that's kind of made me feel sad i
think i'm gonna go cry about it goofing
new zealand people
yeah they're new zealand rent not
australia yeah i think they're new
zealand disabled that
because there's that side of new zealand
i guess but then there's also like
the [ __ ] rugby people like gnarly
new zealand people or i think they're
very one or the other yeah you know it's
good they have like a certain number of
people that they're like these are going
to be our violent people
they're going to keep our culture of
violence and they do that when they come
out as a baby they're like this is a
violent one
send them that way yeah and this is the
softie yeah yeah put him in an office at
ibel studios here at ebal
you're a trailer headquarters
so do you think it's truly i should do
boxing do you think about boxing
i'll pitch him that afterwards
yeah just the whole combat sports arena
that makes sense triangle
yeah have you ever pulled off a triangle
in a in a spar sesh
um
a cut like i said i suck but i have long
legs so that's that's a good one for the
only thing you can do yeah my upper body
is uh weak and unimposing so i have to
rely on my my legs
you're just fighting around yeah i just
flame all around and people get
triangled someone
yeah and like
another person who sucks at it i've done
that before yeah that's cool what
submissions have you gotten off
um
i mean honestly the triangle is the main
one because my my legs are long that's
the easiest thing that's crazy because
i'm good at passing for like it's not
intuitive oh white like a real naked
choke you're like oh yeah i'm squeezing
his neck
none of it isn't it's all emotions you
have to get used to
to figure it out yeah
it's very a lot of the movements are are
foreign if you haven't done it before
yeah like i love it it's like do you do
it yeah i used to oh cool uh it's like
um you know like uh this is a truth of
nature like this is just we would have
found it like if you have religion
and like all over the earth and it's
very old very old art it would all be
different but if everyone was doing jiu
jitsu they would like oh yeah this works
and uh you know triangles and stuff it's
like they've it's just discovering parts
of the hand yeah and if you if there's a
new um
submission or something that someone
discovers like was that actually
something 300 years ago that they were
doing or is that a new yeah as there's
donahue was um mentioned i forgot on
some other podcast podcast section
happening right now but he was um
mentioning that that a ton of martial
arts knowledge got lost in the when the
fire of the light in the library of
alexandria because it was all from you
know all the cult logs of whatever in
the coliseum all of that combat sports
history is just is just gone that was
their ufc library well they could have
been they could i mean you don't know
how sophisticated they were yeah in that
sort of thing but it's all gone
um yeah i mean
that sucks
the japanese i also think that sucks
i'm really sad about the
fire in the library of alexandria
well i think people use that as an
example but like in general there's like
a lot of
historical destruction that happens and
then
whatever happens when new people come in
they just yeah wipe it yeah yeah
um but yeah i don't know how important
that one event was but it's um it makes
sense because if you're a conker and
they're the people that you're raping
and like
chopping off heads and making necklaces
out of or like no please don't do that
that one is our precious library
like oh that one oh that's precious
[ __ ] burn it down
save the library yeah i would just do it
to [ __ ] with them but
that would have been a cool
historical event too if you had a time
machine to witness that would be a
banger yeah burning at the library of
alexandria
yeah where they're like
the nerds lose it's like the jocks
watching the all of the knowledge of
earth up until that point go up in
flames
but what the [ __ ] did they know honestly
they were stupid as [ __ ] they were
drinking like they didn't even have
gutter water
yeah well we don't know maybe there was
you know
like how the pyramids got constructed or
whatever right we don't know how
advanced they got before it got wiped
clean
yeah well not that advanced because they
didn't come up with usb sticks or like a
printing press
well maybe they don't know maybe the way
they were advanced is different than the
way we're advanced now that's true like
the anunnaki or the egyptian egyptian
egyptologists or um like gobletly teppy
yeah whatever you just said and so yeah
that's what i'm talking about oh yeah i
mean yeah i agree with you
um
yeah it's good to have history you know
like the ancient cultures and
um you know like
imagine if there was no asians and we
didn't realize that we could like
meditate and be buddhists and monks yeah
it'd be fine it'd be fun
yeah we don't need asians um
i forgot wasn't that just racist joke
made me forget what i was gonna say
um
oh do you think aliens
helped build the pyramids or we did that
through just human suffering yeah i
think we can do that
you think we did it without help yeah
we don't know how no yeah
they say like they're huge and they have
to travel really far with them
yeah and they're
and they're lined up based on the stars
in some imperfect way
but it
yeah was i think the um
it was how we could have lifted the
weights that
i don't i actually don't know what the
impossible part of it is they're like if
it seems easy it's just like [ __ ]
yeah i mean everyone's stacks
yeah but they say like if you were to
build a ramp to
have a hair on your nose if you were to
build a ramp to the to uh put all the
stones up where they're supposed to go
the ramp would be a bigger project right
pyramids exactly
because you have to build a ceiling
alone
yeah yeah
yeah
it doesn't seem that complicated i mean
stack some bricks yeah you can keep
stacking them until it's really high
yeah
so you can't anymore yeah that makes
sense i think people are very awesome
and we had a lot of free time
we have even more now but we just wasted
it
you think we had a lot of there was a
lot of free time back in the day
were you just concerned about getting
like collectively everyone's free time
added up
yeah i know i have no idea
how much would have stuck to just the
first thing you got sick with you died
like the first time you got sick so
you're dead now that it was must have
been such a bummer
yeah i mean
they died a lot more than us now but
maybe we're just spoiled
yeah from not dying maybe it'd be better
if like a tenth of your friends didn't
exist like it might be better if there
was more turnover
yeah in the human race in general that's
uh japan's having a issue with that
right now right yeah
uh most civilized countries the better
you get as a country the more you start
happening yeah this is great i don't
want children but if you're poor you're
like i need i need more witnesses to
this i need more people though yeah know
how shitty this is so we have one we
need more people suffering well but that
actually is like in the in
poorer countries they have kids because
they need help
yeah growing food you know
yeah
and that's why they keep having kids and
if one dies so like it doesn't we need
another one to help yeah
people are expendable
but they
get more attached to the ones that do
survive and then when they die it's more
devastating
that's
how it works now
i think it all evens out they're as
happy as we are
yeah i think that you know i think that
is true where it's like up to a certain
amount of money you can get happier but
it's just more like
if you're in mortal danger
and beyond that it's it doesn't affect
your happiness very much yeah but i also
only hear you know
people on podcasts talking about this i
don't know i'm sure if you want some
tribe in africa they'd be like we want
the money like we'd be happier with the
money i'd like a pool it'd be like
capitalists yeah they're like we got a
casino you can gamble a couple coconuts
if you if you went to like somewhere in
africa like you guys know that you're as
happy as we are on our eos they're like
go [ __ ] yourself
they are probably happier
like hunting and living as long as
there's no pollution or like you know
war
but even with war people are really
happy in war
i think it's i think it's back to the
free time that if you have too much time
to they're they're living like they're
doing things they can keep living their
lives you have a lot of money you're
sitting in your empty mansion with
nothing to do but
circles in your head then you start
getting sad it's like you built that on
exploitation and you know that and you
can only hang out with other people that
have exploited people and yeah you're
somewhere in the back of your mind it's
you're like it is not quite moral that
i have a house like this
yeah that you have the house but no one
to share it with because
everyone is either an [ __ ] or
a victim
isn't that the weird thing about i think
that
there's like a certain
guilt i think that's why a lot of um
we see such heavy reactions and like in
like on the very extreme ends of social
justice crusaders i think it's it's
because young people nowadays are
we're so much more connected it's the
kind of the first people who are
born uh aware of their privilege
and um i think that kind of fosters like
a deep sense of guilt that they they
feel like they and and they're that's
how they're trying to to fix that
they're trying to earn their privilege
by burning down a police car yeah
exactly that's exactly what i'm saying
like now i get to use my iphone yeah
um
i forgot kids they're spoiled
they're they're aware of their privilege
and uh they want to earn it
i think um
you know like we don't really um
you know i think we could do a lot more
well it's weird being just being in a
first world country you you're like in
action because we could
i don't have much money but i could have
still live on less money like i could
still
sell a bunch of my stuff and move into a
worse apartment and send the money to a
third world country and save lives like
we could all do that it's like all like
at this uh you are you are guilty by
inaction just by living your life
in a country and i think there's people
deal with that in different ways
right but what's the point of saving a
life far away when there's no benefit to
you
uh interesting question
that you should i guess well but you
should stress
none of us do
yeah
i mean it
doesn't make any sense to like if we
were in a system where
like we were seeing like i mean even we
see the homeless and we don't help but
if there was like a productive efficient
use of that resource i'm sure a lot of
people would but that there's not an
infrastructure that helps like send
money
to the right places like it's not
something that we
don't think we're not doing that because
we're like concerned about the
charities aren't being 100
transparent i think
we just live in a weird time where we're
very connected and very disconnected
yeah at the same time i don't know we're
just coming from basically like
primitive past
like we're we're just now getting
computers
like still we're we still have all the
remnants of the old
civilization of babylon and like
hittites and fighting off the huns and
stuff yeah
but uh yeah i mean it's like another
tweet like it's frustrating now because
like we have both but
um you know maybe this is just a
momentary blip and
yeah i don't think about sometimes is if
there was uh
like if aliens had a history book or a
sociologist some sort of
a evolutionary
by like i'm sure if you took the if you
looked at like 10 planets and how life
develops and grows and falls on each of
those 10 planets you can then categorize
them into different ways that life will
develop and things that can happen it
would be very interesting to see in in
from a a removed perspective what
what we are experiencing in that way
like how what is the the name or the
term for how life is progressing on our
planet right this is the mountain dew
phase exactly yeah like they all
they all have mountain dew
a soft sugary drink all mountain dew
will come on this planet yeah it's
called splurge
splurge
that sounds like a mountain dew flavor
yeah they're like oh look they're they
found
that they can uh you know
uh make money off each other and they're
letting it get away from them
and eventually they'll collapse and then
the rodents will take over
right or the right yeah that's also
always happens is at some point they get
mountain dew and then at some point the
rodents
yeah that feeds the rodents do you think
we could fight off the rodents if all
the rodents
could communicate with each other
perfectly and wanted to destroy
human civilization do you think we could
fight them off
i don't know if the size would help or
hurt it
because the size
you could slip in would be a great asset
yeah but then if you're one on one
oh you're [ __ ] but it wouldn't be one
i mean i'm sure there are many more
rodents than there are people so it
would be whatever that ratio it'd be
like could you kill 15. well how many
midgets would it take to overthrow the
civ our civilization
i think that you don't they're mid
little people
aren't little enough
to how dare you my whole families
um
i don't think they are getting the
tactical benefit i kind of have a joke
about this matter they i don't think
they're getting the tactical benefits
of being small i don't think they're
small enough to get the tactical
benefits yet i think they it's not good
you have to be much smaller and then it
would be helpful yeah they're in the
weird gray area yeah where it's just
kind of probably a bummer
but not
useful from a
uh
battlefield perspective
that's why i hate lord of the rings when
they show the dwarves fighting they
don't believe that yeah
did you see the new
the trailers for the new i forget the
movie or tv show where the the guy from
game of thrones
what you know what the guy from game of
thrones is there's a little person and
they all hate uh yeah tyrion yeah he's
peter dinklage he's the lead in a in a
new movie or tv show and he's like he's
badass and he has like a sword and he's
killing all these people oh yeah it's uh
it's like a french thing he's like a
poet and then he's like trying to woo
this woman so he gets like a black guy
with a big dick to show up in person but
he writes the letters for him i don't
remember that part but i do remember him
beating up a lot of people
isn't that true like
the thing about uh the little thing he's
very skilled it's like i don't get your
joints work properly like their legs are
like they sort of waddle
their shoulders i feel like they can't
like stretch all the way back like if
you're trying to fight
i think they can do a bridge like a
bridge position
i feel like that's possible some of them
are acrobats are they not isn't that
like a carnival thing
i think they might be very flexible in
some circumstances but like the average
no i would be
worried about fighting someone like that
though because i feel like they'd take
you out at your knees and then you're on
the same level and then you're in their
world
yeah like have you seen the wrestler
with no legs
i saw that clip yeah yeah that's
how embarrassing i know because you'd
think that he would have a disadvantage
but actually it's hard to take him down
because you can't go for his legs all
about grabbing the legs yeah
i guess you could like you know
push him like he's like couldn't you
just grab his arms and like
like a towel yeah like you're doing
getting the sand off of
helpfully he can like pry your hands off
so his grip strength is probably
incredible
yeah he's walking on those things
that's true i wouldn't know yeah
anyone like anyone like i'm you know in
such a
able body i think it has makes me weak
if someone is like
has some sort of
uh deformity like that i would be i'm
very scared of them because i'm sure
mentally they're iron you know
and that's what matters you're used to
like lounging and i'm just like yeah
um
you know like they you know you also
don't know how they move like what their
strategy like a human you know that's
true left right
yeah
like for bull fighters or the bulls that
they use in bullfighting they never walk
up to the bowl because they don't want
to show how humans they like use a
unicycle or a bicycle or like they walk
they don't use it
it's like they're in spain they're a
bunch of [ __ ] to like do the grooming
on the bowl or whatever they cycle up to
them
you know being
smaller also gives you direct access to
your uh dick and balls which would be
bad
i have
because uf like ufc it's not technically
not real fighting because you can't like
poke in the eyes and like i have this
theory though yeah if they allowed
strikes to the crotch like every martial
art would eventually be about that like
it would all be about ways to rip
someone's dick off they did it in pride
it looked pretty much like the ufc
can you strike to the crotch and pride
someone won a fight by punching their
dude in the dick
see that yeah that is but that's real
fighting and i think over generations
all martial arts would be about
attacking
the dick
yeah really think about that um
i um
i think that's a humorous world i don't
know if it's accurate because like
that's one of the incredibly weak points
of the human body eyes
and dick
i saw the sci-fi movie where this alien
got kicked in the shins and that's where
his testicles were
i forget what it was like a star trek or
something but it's like that's such an
impractical testicles on his shins yeah
were they hanging there like human
testicles or is it just like that is the
equivalent yeah he had like a blue led
screen on his [ __ ] leg on his shin or
something no like that's where the nuts
are yeah it wasn't just like a sloth
it would be terrible to play soccer you
need like shin guards
um if you had balls on your shoes yeah
yeah i mean it kind of hurts to get
kicked in this [ __ ] normally why that'd
be terrible if it was your balls were
there too yeah i don't think they
studied uh
physiology that well they were just like
it's a funny idea but why you know why
would that be i don't think that's
weirder than where our balls are now
does it seem kind of weird where dick
and balls are located if you really
think about it
um wouldn't it make more sense if like
from a reproductive standpoint if it
was in your chest or like your hand or
something like that it seems like
they're in a weird place chest bump
yeah if they're like avatar where their
hair is like the their penis and then
they [ __ ] their horses
yeah ponytail and they it's both right
it attaches to people and the horse
it was a
it was an oversight on there what if you
could like
tell like oh you've been in a horse
recently
yes
why are you thinking about grass so much
i think you can probably tell i think
you can deal with people
yeah i feel like if someone [ __ ] a
horse recently and i just met them i'd
be like
i could sense it has this dick been in a
horse you have a deep secret like this
is how you have to ride your horse you
have to stick your dick in it that would
be so funny
like to tame the horse to break the
horse you have to put your dick in it
and then it will respect you yeah grab
the mane spank it a little
it kind of makes sense you know like
if you're gonna break a horse you gotta
[ __ ] it and then it'll
show it then you can ride it yeah
or else it's not gonna respect you
yeah but then the horse is going to be
traumatized
because if you're a horse and your dick
is that big and like a person with our
tiny dicks is trying to tame you you're
like get the [ __ ] out of here like i
don't respect you it's more
uncomfortable and it's like it's more of
a symbolic thing it's like oh come on
man you don't have to rape me right now
yeah
but is it
rape if it's a
a battle for
i guess it's if he's trying to do it too
it's so strong that's right
uh yeah yeah if he's trying to do it to
you too yeah if you're both
trying to rape each other
that's still no it's still rape it's all
right yeah
yeah i mean we figured just because he
deserves it doesn't mean it's not rape
exactly that's what i've always said
[Laughter]
that's when you tell my children yeah
like
yeah
when i'm getting raped i'm like yeah
don't think that just because i was an
[ __ ] to you that
you get to do this how often do you get
raped
um
[Music]
bi-monthly
twice a year
penetration
yeah i think that's that has to yeah
that's what we're just like unwanted
contact
unlimited contact is not
it's different
somewhere there's a line where we're in
cross is over yeah
um
i would say i try to get raped at least
once a month yeah oh you try to yeah but
then it's not rape is it
you got it backwards yeah it's like all
about mentality never happened to your
christian public school yeah
yeah i've never been raped because i
wanted it i was asking for it the whole
time right
that's good advice yeah
if you're about to get raped just start
wanting it and then yeah
this is it won't be rape a terrible
this is terrible i'm glad you're gonna
say where you worked
yeah that's a hundred percent why i
didn't say that
i didn't know that we'd be delving this
into
the uh where the line is for rape and
just
yeah giving advice to people who are
about to bear
terrible advice but i guess we're here
now so
yeah i mean it'll throw the your
opponent off you know
if your opponent thinks you're small
is your
assault or europe i guess i don't think
they've ever been called an opponent
before that
it's more of like a video game your
perpetrator yeah your dancing partner
for the evening yes
um but yeah i mean i think rape is a
terrible thing
we agree on that give me another first
point
i love it um
i love
condemning rape in all its forms
that's your brand really obsessing your
brand before anti-rape anti-rape
um i think that
unless you want it then it's not right
unless it's a um consenting non-consent
situation
yeah you ever been in one of those
consenting not yes really yeah like
rough sex
but like i'm gonna tell you no but you
keep going sort of thing yeah
how was that it was great
um i mean
it's like uh yeah i mean like a lot of
like the bdsm community like there's a
real rape problem there and like people
hear that they're like whoa no way the
people that simulate rape with each
other are always raping each other
there's a problem with that in the bdsm
community i think so
i would think it would be almost the op
aren't they all i hope so
drawing lines where they need it's hard
to tell though cause like once it
happens people blow it up and they're
like look i guess that community
probably attracts a lot of if i was
a rapist
yeah i would just say i was very into
bdsm
right
yeah
yeah
or if you're like a pedophile just say
you love volunteering at schools exactly
that's good advice
what's some other advice you have for a
pedophile
well we're not speaking as someone who
uh goes around in a van and
went to a private christian school um i
learned from it i think that's hilarious
like
um yeah bdsm it's just like a cover
yeah are you into bdsm stuff yeah
tastefully i mean like a little bit you
know but then there's a line where it's
like yeah everyone has a limit yeah
yeah it's like not fun anymore this is
just like this yeah this is like a lot
of work afterwards yeah like if there's
like cleanup involved like or may not
like clean up but like medical
procedures that have to be
applied afterwards
gauze yeah speaking stitches yeah yeah i
feel like i can match that energy but
i'm not gonna bring that energy
right to the arena yeah you gotta
communicate
you gotta communicate
absolutely yeah and i do a lot of
communicating with my fists
it's very kung-fu of you
uh yeah i mean the fist is the way
the way is the fist
we touched on
transgender
rape
and little people so is there anything
else you wanted to ruin my life with
what we're talking about oh
um i mean i'll take us to get into
abortion we can get into um don't you
think we need a revolution of the
workers and class contract communism
yeah that's from the kind yes that's
good dialectical materialism
um
owning the means of production
yeah which according to his ability each
according to his needs
i think we're too late i think we're
[ __ ] i think we're fine yeah yeah
i mean russia tried communism another
invading ukraine
that's true
don't try it cause effect yeah um i
think that we would be i think we could
um
endure as a species
right now even if we could all get on
the same page
and conduct like as if we could you know
like a cell can communicate with all
other parts of the cell and allocate
resources
um so that the cell survives i think if
we could do that we have the capability
to with the internet i think if we
could do that as a as a species
today
we would be fine and then we could
actually figure out
this surviving yeah on the planet [ __ ]
but um
we that will never happen so we have too
much you know entrenched histories and
whatnot so i think we're screwed isn't
that interesting that everyone of our
generation is like yeah the world's
going to end yeah we're all just on the
same page about it being the end it
doesn't feel it's weird it doesn't feel
like it's sustainable or that it's
everyone i mean i don't know if i'm
gonna have kids because the world might
be over it's like a very casual thing
that we all talk about
yeah i was uh listening to this podcast
and they were like
another podcast
uh we should just play it but
um they were talking about how like uh
they're like now you have to fight for
it like sometimes uh you know
commercialism needs to be defended and
what we're fighting for is mindless
consumption
it's like well the best part of it is
that we don't have to fight for it
that's the reason why we're doing it
like if we had to fight for it then we
wouldn't do it but if you if we have to
fight for just like the commercialism
then it's like it's not worth it if
we're gonna fight for something we might
as well fight for something worth
fighting for instead of just like the
whole benefit of this system is that you
don't have to sacrifice anything
but you wouldn't lay down your
life or
pepsi
not like kylie jenner did
what did she do she did a oh
yeah that was so
yeah she put a flower into the
right when all the protests were
happening yeah yeah it was fairy flower
in the country like handed
a pepsi into a person of color they were
like thank you
awesome
thirsty i got some pepsi yeah
yeah do that voice
are you gonna burn down this cop car and
get off welfare a little bit of a texas
twang to that i have no idea
it changes i never i'm so bad at it
voice
i would love to see a video of you
practicing impressions because you're so
stoic and you know
low-key but i do just jokes so it would
help if i could do you know voices
yeah but
well i mean mitch hedberg what was he he
didn't do any famous impressions
no
no he didn't but i will never be that so
i need as many assets as i could
possibly as i could possibly get well
you are from l.a you just a crew
personality traits like it's a video
game that's true i have 17 right now
and you're not using any of them for
your sets no it's just
dead man and boring
you can you just choose not to
talk about myself yeah or to be
entertaining no
i think you're great
i think you're great too thanks i would
love to do voices though
yeah
maria bamford i'd love to be able to do
that with my voice don't you think like
it has to come naturally like if you
don't feel it it probably means
i think it has to come naturally in the
context of the joke but i think you can
work on skills
that will then eventually find their way
into your standout
then i mean what they say about burr
right he's always or some comedians you
know he's doing act outs and then he's
trying all these new things he's always
building his yeah his skills yeah he's
trying new things he's leaning on the
mic stand he's
not leaning on the nightstand he's in
genius yeah
he's shaking the mic stand
um
i uh i think that you
value authenticity and i think is
getting serious
and i think that's a problem
we're gonna break you of that habit
right now by
riding you like a horse no
this is the part of the podcast where
you [ __ ] me
are we there already
i mean we were talking about it so
um break me like a horror song
that's the new brokeback mountain break
me like a horse
that's a hardcore thing to say
oh yeah i mean that's a lot of dating
a lot of dating is like vulnerable but
like not but also
it's like i'm vulnerable but i'm cool
yeah at the same time i'm letting you do
this too yeah i have walls up but
they'll open for you if you want yeah
you're lucky you got to be in here yeah
is that what you say in your van
you're lucky you get to be in here yeah
this is actually one of the best vans to
get uh abducted in that's true
um yeah because that you would just do a
podcast and kick them out
yeah
i uh
what are you using the band for nowadays
just to drive around just as a [ __ ]
car yeah dang
yeah it's weird and cartwright with a
giant efficient yeah
solar panels
i carry around like kitchen and 12
gallons of water everywhere i go nice i
have a bong in there wow
yeah i have a bed i like the bed because
sometimes i get drunk and i'm just like
i'm just gonna lay down completely flat
completely yeah does make sense yeah
um i love it it's a good you know
conversation thing it's a little messy
right now
yeah but you know
yeah i mean people say it looks like
[ __ ] but
yeah like you know how you can tell how
attractive you are by like the
expression people have on their face
after they see your face
sure i guess yeah
i don't know i don't know that's not how
i judge my droppings but you oh you see
their faces change myself i guess yeah
it's like damn i must be ugly today no i
uh i guess i am uh too you know like
it's probably not physical
yeah i mean i i got the sense that i'm
not really like
upper tier physical attractiveness you
talk about that in your act a little bit
yeah i mean you were kind of i mean
you weren't dealt very good cards being
korean looking in america where we you
know right
yeah
um yeah i mean i think asians look uh
more effeminate which is
but that is cool nowadays yeah i'm like
justin bieber and there are some i do
see some
uh asian dudes with very hot women some
more more now
maybe than before yeah it's happening
yeah they're working out they're
dressing nice there are some ripped
dudes who are very asian and very rich
yeah yeah the dedication and the drive
and the loneliness you should do that
why don't you become one of those one of
those asian guys with the tank top like
this and
i think that if i had to look like that
to get laid i would resent whoever was
[ __ ] me
yeah
i'd be like oh you don't like my natural
form
it's like without makeup on this is just
me but do you resent that that like
now that you have some clout and you're
getting late or you're like you're doing
this for the class yeah
you're like yes
i don't respect human beings in general
no i um you know like i i'm more
attractive now than i was when i was a
loser
and i would work out but i got like a
neck injury and
i don't really mean working out is that
important i mean stephen hawking was an
amazing uh person and he was bedridden
turned out all the time
that's why he ended up like that yeah
he's working out too much
yeah he went big and then went small
it's like your teeth you have to break
it i don't know
trying to do a callback
wait to what to your teeth how they're
like we're gonna spread them out and
spread them and bring them back together
and give us three thousand dollars yeah
pretty cool
uh i do i don't think working out is i
think it's in important like we were
saying before in that uh for as far as
it goes for your mental health and then
beyond that it's a hobby yeah you know
yeah
yeah i mean um but i do think we do look
better yeah man i think we're still you
know grounded in you know these bodies
that are
used to hunting and running from prey
and stuff in it a little bit of exercise
will make you feel better yeah
for sure yeah but beyond that
like working out i think is like
an effective way to do it it's just one
of the more boring ways and i think yeah
a hobby would be better yeah
i think it's good to do especially if
you're doing a sport it's like oh this
is going to help me get better at the
sport
but to just do it um it takes a special
kind of person and usually the people
that do it like are writing like they're
very analytical and
they're hot it's like they're sad they
like that yeah they're very sad but
they're like i know my macros yeah i
know exactly how sad i was today
i'm gonna need to do three bench presses
and two squats to
because i got some sad news and then
everything will be okay yeah it's like
hail mary's
say three hail marys and yeah exactly
yeah it's all the same yeah we're all
it's modern pennants or uh confessionals
yeah your penis at the [ __ ] gym the
altar the iron altar yeah the altar of
tostas
pumping
awesome reworkout sex i like pre-workout
that's my favorite part working out yeah
cocaine light yeah
yeah and then you just don't work out
yeah you're just on instagram but like
[ __ ] into it
you're liking at a path at a pace
that's unmatched
so do would you ever run a marathon
no i know i'm not designed i'm not a
good runner i didn't know about swimming
you'd be a good swimmer i'm better at so
i'm better in the water than i am my
knees suck so yeah
i have problems quickly if i run i did
basketball as a as a child and i liked
it a lot but
not
it's a little
knee heavy i don't i can't jump i don't
have hops at all
um i think i think it's a skill
yeah basketball
i mean jumping jumping yeah but i mean i
know like
know what my body i'm getting
more acquainted with what my body is
good at and what it's not good at and
running long distances is something i'd
ha i have i have to fix my posture i'm
trying to fix my posture and stuff and
that might help with the running but
right now it's terrible all running
it'll ditches my legs will blow up if i
run
for a long time how about you
um
i would like to yeah i did a lot of
soccer back in the day
so you are a runner yeah i've been
running
i've been known to run
um i would love to do it just to see if
i can i mean i think that's like yeah i
mean a mental battle yeah i don't know
how often human beings were wrestling
and rolling around with each other and
trying to murder each other in
hand-to-hand combat
um i mean i think without weapons before
yeah well that was all about weapons
yeah yeah i don't know how like i don't
know if we're designed to be mma
fighters no it's a cool thing i mean for
me personally yeah they are it's better
for my body fish
most of them are just designed to like
eat plankton or whatever they're not
designed to [ __ ] up other fish like our
goal that would be with their body [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] badass boss rooting fish
yeah that could just palm stroller
doesn't even eat it or anything just
beats it up and moves on yeah it's just
only we do that like huh yeah they're
kind of the apex predator
yeah but we don't other animals don't
beat each other up
to prove they can
you know they're
for food
deer or like elk that the big horn rams
that are for sex but it's
it's not for
you know they're not getting drunk at a
bar and doing it for fun or to prove
something yeah it's for mating or
food well like sea lions when they see
another male they're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here [ __ ] yeah dominance
yeah
i guess that's why we do it too yeah
back in the
in the brain somewhere yeah but it's
like if you if you have a species that's
just constantly [ __ ] itself up it's
probably not
the best strategy yeah
but you should have some uh to add a
certain point like it's probably good to
like build the strongest but then at a
certain point
yeah you need cooperation yeah isn't
that the new theory of how we came to be
is like all the beta mail i
heard this on a podcast i'm sure all the
beta males got together and
teamed up and killed all the alphas and
then civilization was born we like took
out all the alphas
yeah and one with democracy
i think i mean i think that back in the
past it wasn't so hierarchical it was
more like a herd of
deer like we're just in a group there's
no like alpha deer there's we're just
all sort of trying not to get eaten by
wolves alpha deer
yeah i would love to see an elephant
here though sounds like a pokemon yeah
like an elk with big horns horns all the
way down the back yeah that'd be [ __ ]
cool yeah like the fabio of deer yeah
is that the alpha it's fabian the alpha
the hair is like
um but yeah i mean um i love exploring
my animal side
um wow
it's hot
hot that you said that
tell me more about your animal side
i'm slinging i got little rocks oh very
yeah very primitive of you yeah
are you good with that you think you
could that seems unreliable as a
defensive weapon
you need space
yeah yeah and is it accurate
yeah you mean you can get accurate right
uh you can practice as much as you can
and yeah you can get pretty good at it
it was the most deadly ranged weapon
before the crossbow
okay so before there was a ranged weapon
for this
before the result
it's more there's no way a sling with a
rock is deadlier than a bow and arrow
yeah but that's there's no way that's
true you see joe rogan out there with
the sling to kill an elk
not maybe a modern bow but like a sling
um maybe for people you can throw huge
rocks really it's like a cannonball
and it whistles through the air right
but like i feel like i could kill a bear
if i was really good with a bow and
arrow
but i don't think i could kill a bear if
i was really good at hucking rocks at it
right
um
i mean
i disagree with your assessment what
podcast did you hear that on look up
balearic slingers um i mean it was
pretty deadly in a in in terms of an
army
like if you had a
legion of slaves a legion of slingers
yeah
but yeah i could see that like like if
you had like a 500 rocks coming at you
that would be
yeah i mean guessing
there's ammo that you could and you
could do it oh it's everywhere yeah yeah
if you're like
you don't want to fight a slinger in
like a riverbed yeah that would be a
nightmare you want to take him to the
desert yeah he just has to fling sand at
you a little beveled
really hard but it's they're too small
it's not working just cover your eyes or
you're going to get stung yeah
that's that's you shouldn't reveal that
on the podcast because that's some
strategy that people can use against you
you know if you're using a sling yeah
i'm uh out of my element i have to be
nice here we're on sand yeah exactly you
can blind people for a second but then
you're screwed not doing lasting damage
it's like magneto's prison
yeah exactly the next one yeah
um but yeah
i uh i love ancient weapons i love um
you know just
you know because like
we need to help our bodies and then also
need to go in the future so
it's good to do both
we need to help our bodies and we need
to go in the future yeah what
our bodies are wanting animal things so
we need to help it get rid of that and
then we also need to like
invent the
craft right like well yeah that's well
that's kind of what we were talking
about before like you need to honor the
your body yeah and what it needs
and what it wants and then that frees up
your mind yeah
i just think that uh we shouldn't focus
too much on the animal side i think the
focus should be on the future side
it's one of these cameras just on your
mouth
you see that one that's just your mouth
angle uh-huh can we cut to that camera
it's like um it's cut to the mouth
camera
mouth cam yes mouth cam
yeah that sounds a little loud hold on
that for the rest of it
that's good that they have that camera
yeah
oh there we go back to the mouthpiece
what's moving there we go is there a
camera on the camera
i know it seems like there are more
angles on that screen than there are
cameras in this room
i don't know what's going on
can you guys hear me yeah yeah we can
hear you yeah
our producer is talking to us right now
hey so uh we're at like a hour 20. you
guys want to
put a bookend on this in a few minutes
he's like yeah he's like this is
[ __ ]
you should wrap it up stop talking about
slings i know i'm sorry that i said that
about rape
no that wasn't when he chimed in it was
about the slings
and the ancient weaponry yeah ancient
weaponry was actually in fact invented
in ancient
babylonia all right well that's good
that you can use a sling are you
confident in your ability to defend
yourself with that no
i mean i can scare someone with it
they'll be like oh i don't want to go
there but i'm not that accurate with it
right now yeah
but this is scary fun yeah
it goes really fast i bet you it does
the noise that a rock makes when it's
you know going that fast yeah
strikes fear into your anime yeah the
noise
is that what it sounds like
i can imagine it sounds like
it sounded like a bear when i first did
i was like what the [ __ ] is that i was
like is there a bear
or am i just hucking rocks right
yeah i mean it's it's dangerous because
i did it a couple times where it's like
i don't know where that landed and if it
hit something it's and it was living
it's probably yeah you're practicing
this practicing this on like a
playground or
you know in the chili's whereas where
you go in parking lots in the desert in
the texas desert the deserts yeah when i
was camping i was out in the desert
slinging i like that you call it
slinging yeah that's cool it's just
something to do like you were saying
about your body something that puts you
in your body yeah that's true
and uh yeah i mean i it is violent and
aggressive but you know that i think
that's a very natural thing to want to
get good at yeah you get it out and then
you go on stage until you're [ __ ] jokes
that's great yeah
um uh do you want to say anything
before we leave
no i think we covered all the things i
didn't want to talk about so that's good
yeah yeah what are you uh most nervous
about
that we should probably
i don't think i think i'm nothing in
this book i think i put it all on you i
think yeah i think that's like well
maybe not it might be my downfall i hope
i'm sorry if it is yeah just don't do
anything successful send me a pri if
you're send me a private dm we could
talk about it don't
blast me
yeah let's talk
i'm gonna change my opinion if it means
keeping my
career of not having a real job intact
no i think that we're uh
um hilarious geniuses
does everything perfectly so i mean i
had fun i don't really know yeah
what else to do with these podcasts i
mean yeah well this is very yeah it's
very uh
i don't know i mean that's very new for
me i'm not i've worked a lot at getting
good at stand up recently but not the
time
it's podcasting the thing to do it's
like mitch hedberg's joke it's like hey
you got good at comedy can you yeah
right yeah can you podcast you're good
at farming are you good at cooking can
you farm yeah it's interesting
yeah i mean might as well it's like
it's not a passion of mine but right
it's easy to do and it makes me feel
like i'm
working yeah
you don't have a passion for content
i kind of do you didn't want to grow up
being a content creator
i did i listened to tucker max and red
maddox
i don't know what those are but it
sounds good
um they're like proto internet
celebrities oh
oh i wasn't
i
read about some of those people but i
forget all of them
so can i find this on like stitcher
premium or
spotify podcast yeah it's going to be
unable for sure i hope that enables i
can upload the whole thing and start my
youtube
because
you know i like documenting yeah they
said we have to sign something
when we leave this
studio yeah try to download documents
let's not do that
let's walk out
yeah and not sign anything let's just
waste their time
i'm getting paid for this right
it bulls bang me
can i get one of those desks they have
to stand up at i mean i hope that we
don't have to pay for it but you might
have to pay for that i don't know how
money works
i got here early and they were talking
about business stuff i was like i'm
gonna talk to hans i don't know what's
going on here yeah the business man
commodity
i'm so i'm a hat and i'm happy about it
i'm vehicle thanks for being appreciated
i'm glad that it's happening it's like
not really me it's like a character that
i play on tv
kissing strippers yeah does that taste
like as much dick as i think it would no
it's fine okay i like it
no yeah i haven't tasted dick i have
tasted like dry mouth right yeah but
they're just high yeah yeah well yeah
i'm sure they could clip that that could
be the promo
okay that's good yeah thanks guys thank
you hans
thank you jordan
you